bien
[Música]
luego de seis días encallado el
portacontenedores se originen comenzó a
moverse en el canal de suez la popa del
audio de 400 metros de 200 mil toneladas
ha sido reflotada parcialmente y se
alejó de la orilla occidental del canal
las autoridades estiman que tomará entre
tres y cinco días retomar el tráfico en
el canal de suez
hoy comienza el juicio por la muerte del
afroamericano georges flow de un jurado
se reunirá para escuchar argumentos que
determinarán si el procedimiento
realizado por el ex policía de
minneapolis derecha bien fue o no un
asesinato joven de 45 años se declaró
inocente de los cargos de asesinato y
alegó que estaba siguiendo el
entrenamiento policial
el presidente de chile sebastián piñera
propuso al congreso una reforma para
aplazar las elecciones de los delegados
que redactaron la nueva constitución así
como los comicios municipales debido al
empeoramiento de la pandemia el
mandatario planea cambiar las fechas del
10 y 11 de abril al 15 y 16 semanas
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 cierra blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en egipto donde la autoridad del canal
de suez se anunció que se logró mover el
portacontenedores seberg idem y ha sido
parcialmente reclutado sin embargo el
buque bloquea todavía esta vital vía
marítima luego de quedar encallado el
pasado martes causando un gran atasco de
embarcaciones el cierre por seis días
del canal de suez ha generado un
embotellamiento en una de las vías
fluviales más transitadas del mundo y
por la que pasa el 10% del comercio
mundial
emitiendo un fuerte sonido
el ever given expresa su satisfacción
tras ser parcialmente reflotado después
de casi una semana encallado en el canal
de suez la posición del barco ha sido re
orientada al 80 por ciento en la
dirección correcta la popa se movió a
102 metros de la orilla el presidente
egipcio abdel fatal sí sí mandó un
mensaje de congratulación a través de su
cuenta de twitter hoy los egipcios han
conseguido poner fin a la crisis del
barco atascado en el canal de suez a
pesar de las grandes dificultades
técnicas que rodean esta operación desde
todos los puntos de vista y al
establecer el curso normal de las cosas
con manos egipcias el mundo entero puede
estar seguro de la trayectoria de sus
bienes y necesidades que se transportan
a través de esta arteria de navegación
los remolcadores han estado empujando al
enorme barco y las dragadoras sacaron
más de 27.000 metros cúbicos de arena y
barro de alrededor del portacontenedores
ahora el buque ha quedado recto pero
todavía no está libre
ha llevado tanto tiempo porque tuve
y trabajar a un lado del buque es
probable que estén ahora en una mejor
posición pero no me confiaría hasta que
no lo veamos bajar por el canal y más de
360 buques se han quedado atrapados en
un atasco marítimo a ambos lados del
canal
esperando para poder atravesar este
pasaje marítimo vital se calcula que
este retraso podría costar entre 5 y 8
mil millones de euros al comercio
internacional esperando a cruzar el
canal hay material electrónico o ropa
coches pero también al menos 20 barcos
con ganado con decenas de miles de
animales vivos en riesgo de ser
sacrificados por el deterioro de las
condiciones en las bodegas algunos
barcos decidieron que sería más rápido
redirigir su ruta hacia la punta sur de
áfrica si con la marea alta los
remolcadores no consiguen desencallar al
haber viven hacia la mitad del canal se
tendrán que bajar los contenedores para
hacerlo más liviano en una operación que
podría durar semanas grupos yihadistas
tomaron el sábado el control de la
ciudad de palma en el norte de
mozambique dejando decenas de muertos la
región de cabo delgado rica en gas y
minerales preciosos se ha convertido en
los últimos años en el objetivo de una
creciente insurgencia islamista dejando
más de 700.000 civiles desplazados por
la escalada de violencia y una crisis
humanitaria en el norte de ese país
africano
la crisis de seguridad hace saltar todas
las alarmas en mozambique la
organización human right watch ha pedido
a la comunidad internacional que redoble
sus esfuerzos para combatir la
insurgencia islámica en el país después
de la toma de la ciudad norteña de palma
por militares de harlistas
es hora de que la comunidad de
desarrollo del sur de áfrica trate este
asunto como una prioridad y de que las
autoridades de mozambique generar el
mundo lo que está ocurriendo y la ayuda
que necesitan en el asalto a palma fue
el último de una serie de ataques en la
región de cabo delgado rica en gas la
provincia posee varios yacimientos de
carbón y gas así como importantes
reservas de petróleo en alta mar también
es una de las dos regiones donde la
mayoría de la población es musulmana en
una nación tradicionalmente cristiana en
la última década varias multinacionales
extranjeras como total y exxonmobil han
invertido masivamente en la explotación
de los recursos de cabo delgado
incluyendo un proyecto de 20 mil
millones de dólares para extraer gas
natural licuado conocido como la planta
gene l pero estos proyectos se han
convertido en blancos para las milicias
que lanzaron una insurgencia en 2017 en
impulsada por las privaciones religiosas
así como la pobreza y las desigualdades
generalizadas el grupo rebelde al
shabaab plantea una serie de ataques
brutales contra objetivos
gubernamentales y civiles en la ciudad
en 2019 los islamistas prometieron
lealtad al grupo estado islámico y en
2020 lograron capturar en dos ocasiones
la estratégica ciudad portuaria norteña
de mushing boat a praia a pesar de hacer
de la seguridad su máxima prioridad y de
contar con la ayuda de potencias
extranjeras y mercenarios el gobierno
mozambiqueño tiene dificultades para
hacer frente a la insurgencia unas 2.600
personas han muerto por los ataques
desde 2017 y otras 700 mil se han visto
obligadas a huir de sus hogares según
naciones unidas
pasamos ahora el continente americano y
lunes inicia el juicio contra derechos
saben el ex oficial de policía acusado
de la muerte del afroamericano georges
floyd quien estaba bajo su custodia y a
quien aparentemente asfixió al ponerle
su rodilla en el cuello para reducirlo
el hombre podría enfrentar una condena
de 40 años de prisión durante la jornada
de ayer se realizaron vigilias en la
esquina donde falleció floyd en el lugar
estuvo nuestro corresponsal anto nivel
sí que nos da todos los detalles pues lo
cierto es que hay muchísima explicación
aquí en la ciudad de mineápolis que por
cierto se ha blindado el centro de la
ciudad donde está la corte donde se va a
juzgar a partir de mañana las acciones
de deere que chauvín y pero también en
la población está de alguna manera dicen
estar satisfechos porque dicen que por
ahora sí que se va a poder dar justicia
a esos hechos en estos momentos se está
realizando una vigilia aquí a mis
espaldas en el lugar donde el policía de
mineápolis durante más de ocho minutos
colocó su rodilla
en el cuello de georges floyd aquí se
está recordando la figura de él pero
también dicen que hay que pedir justicia
por otros casos de violencia racial que
se siguen dando en eeuu pasamos ahora a
otras noticias el gobierno salvadoreño
confirmó la nacionalidad de una mujer
que murió tras ser sometida por policías
municipales mexicanos en quintana roo y
ofreció total apoyo y acompañamiento a
la familia de la víctima en medio de
quejas internacionales y denuncias de
racismo asociaciones feministas y de
migrantes se reconocieron como victoria
esperanza salazar de 36 años a las
mujeres que aparece en un vídeo en el
que la asfixia a uno de los cuatro
agentes de la dirección municipal de
seguridad pública de tulum el alcalde de
esa ciudad víctor más está anunció que
va a separar a los policías del cargo
pero no ha aclarado si están detenidos
ni porque la sometieron el presidente
salvadoreño en allí buque le rechazó
este hecho a través de su cuenta de
twitter
y estoy seguro que el gobierno mexicano
aplicará todo el peso de la ley a los
responsables somos pueblos hermanos
personas malas hay en todos lados no
olvidemos eso mi pésame a la familia de
victoria sobre todo a sus dos hijas a
quienes les daré toda la ayuda posible
vamos ahora hasta chile donde el
presidente sebastián piñera anunció la
decisión de aplazar las elecciones
previstas para los próximos días del 10
y 11 de abril esto a causa de la
acelerada aumento en los contagios
porque hoy 19 que vive ese país el
presidente dijo que enviará al congreso
un proyecto de reforma constitucional
para que los comicios se realicen el 15
y 16 de mayo en los comicios además las
autoridades de autoridades locales se
van a elegir los delegados que van a
redactar una nueva constitución del país
fruto de las multitudinarias protestas
antigobierno del año 2019 desde santiago
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna con
todos los detalles
el presidente chileno sebastián piñera
anunció el domingo por la noche la
postergación de las elecciones previstas
para el 10 y el 11 de abril que pasarán
a celebrarse ahora el 15 y el 16 de mayo
a través de una reforma constitucional
que ha de ser aprobada en el congreso se
trata de una decisión difícil afirmó el
mandatario que se toma en función de dos
objetivos proteger la salud de los
chilenos y proteger también la
democracia las altas tasas de contagio
que se han producido en el país en los
últimos días podrían inhibir que muchas
personas acudieran a votar y restar así
tanto participación como legitimidad a
un proceso histórico en el que 155
chilenos serán elegidos para elaborar
una constitución y se elegirán también
alcaldes concejales y gobernadores cada
vez serán más voces en los últimos días
los que apostaban por aplazar estas
elecciones ante la crítica situación
sanitaria que atraviesa el país chile
vive su peor momento en la pandemia
hasta ahora con cuatro días consecutivos
en los que se han superado los siete mil
casos de contagios a diario y que
podrían traducirse en ingresos en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos que ya
se encuentran completamente desbordadas
a un 95 96 por ciento de su capacidad
trabajadores de la salud muy mermados
entre un 25 y un 30 por ciento de ellos
tienen licencias médicas en muchos casos
asociados a problemas de salud mental
vamos ahora hasta europa específicamente
a inglaterra donde este lunes comienza
una nueva fase de reapertura tras varios
meses de restricción es consecuencia de
la pandemia del coi 19 las autoridades
permiten a partir de ahora las reuniones
al aire libre incluido en jardines
privados de hasta 6 personas o de dos
hogares así como los deportes en el
exterior entre otras medidas de alivio
de las restricciones volverán a ser
autorizadas las bodas con hasta seis
personas sin embargo se mantienen
cerrados todos los comercios no
esenciales a pesar de estas
flexibilización es el primer ministro
británico boris johnson pide precaución
a la población
en la región de parís los hospitales y
los médicos alertan a las autoridades
que las medidas contra el kobe 19 no son
suficientes muchas unidades de cuidados
intensivos están repletas en essen
sunday y un suburbio al norte de parís
la situación es todavía peor y los
vecinos piden más restricciones
esto es sant dennis bajo medidas
reforzadas contra el cob y 19 el mercado
está repleto cualquiera puede entrar y
salir sin preocuparse por la distancia
social
para muchos vecinos se deberían aplicar
más restricciones para mantener el virus
bajo control
a esto le llamas cuarentena
no estoy ni a favor ni en contra pero
necesitamos medidas sanitarias
regulación de la circulación
esto es anarquía ligera será la acción
al accidente sin embargo la zona es una
de las más golpeadas en francia la tasa
de contagio semanal está casi en 800
casos por cada 100.000 personas más del
doble de la media nacional
ser una de las zonas más pobres de
francia tiene que ver con la rápida
expansión del virus
los residentes de aquí no tienen más
opción que ir en transporte público
viven en apartamentos pequeños donde
aislarse con un familiar infectado es
difícil debido a malas usan la semi
las escuelas causan una preocupación
particular a pesar de que trabajar desde
casa fue difícil durante la cuarentena
los alumnos quieren que esta escuela
cierre temporalmente casi 50 estudiantes
se contagiaron sólo en este mes llevado
como a cypress pongan no me preocupa por
mí pero si me contagio pondría mi
familia en 10
los cuidados intensivos en sense and
then y están llenos la zona tiene la
tasa de vacunación más baja en la
francia metropolitana menos del 7 por
ciento de la población está vacunada la
mitad de los vacunados en parís
la justicia francesa condenó a serbia el
segundo grupo farmacéutico del país por
el inmediato de un medicamento que
muchos médicos recetaban como
adelgazante dentro del tratamiento de la
diabetes y al que se considera
responsable de cientos de muertes el
tribunal correccional de parís consideró
acería es culpable de los delitos de
homicidios y heridas involuntarias
además de engaño agravado y le impuso
una multa de 2.7 millones de euros para
los jueces el laboratorio no tuvo en
cuenta deliberadamente los riesgos es
que sabía que causaba el uso del
mediador que en francia se comercializó
desde 1976 hasta el año 2009 un período
durante el cual lo tomaron unas 5
millones de personas
australia renueva su gobierno tras una
serie de escándalos que han sacudido al
país el primer ministro de scott moore
vinson anunció cambios que aumentan la
presencia de mujeres en el gobierno esto
tras degradar de sus cargos a dos
poderosos diestros que estaban en el
centro de dos denuncias de abusos
sexuales dentro del parlamento los
índices de aprobación de morín son se
han visto golpeados en las últimas
semanas cayendo en más de siete puntos
porcentuales y se encuentran en un nivel
más bajo en un año
para obtener estos resultados para las
mujeres australianas debemos colaborar
se lograrán escuchando se lograrán
actuando juntas y no se lograrán
dividiendo a las australianas y
separando las y teniendo más conflictos
lo lograremos y los australianos se unen
para abordar estos problemas tan serios
y significativos los cambios que estoy
anunciando hoy proporcionarán una vez
más la representación femenina más
sólida en un gabinete del gobierno
australiano hasta aquí el informativo
france24 continúa con nosotros muy buen
día
[Música]